My name is Andy Isaacson, and
I'm a Fullstack engineer at Udacity.
When I say I'm a Fullstack engineer,
it kind of means I do a little
bit of the both, right.
I kind of do some front end and
some back end.
My background,
when I first started out programming,
I was doing hardcore computer science.
And I kind of got interested in
thinking about the user more, so
looking at aspects of psychology.
Thinking about how people learn and
how people think about
the systems that they're using.
I really was interested in building
interfaces that worked well for people.
And the more projects that I did,
the more I found myself kind of
floating to that role within my team,
being the guy who put together the
system that everything was talking to.
And actually since coming to Udacity,
my sweet spot is really thinking about
how to build the systems
that power the front ends.
The front end is cool because it exists
right in the moment that
someone's using it.
It's right just on their screen.
But the back end sort of covers
everybody who's using a big system
at the same time.
And so it's really kind of fun
to build the sort of larger
piece that's kind of
underpinning everything, and
thinking about some of the unique
problems that come up there.
One of the backend pieces that I'm
working on right now is what's going to
be the foundation of the next
iteration of the Udacity platform.
So we're migrating from what was
kind of a monolithic application
on top of Google app engine into
a network of micro services.
And so, putting all the backend
underpinnings in place,
before we can even think about
building out the interfaces.
With the backend you really want to
take that step back and think critically
about is this going to slowly eat up
all my memory and destroy my server?
Is this going to create a security
hole that somebody might be
able to use to get
information they shouldn't?
Or is this going
to be a performance bottleneck
that'll screw everything else up?
And so, yeah, there's a little
more kind of structured thinking,
I think, that goes into that.
If you've got a problem with a frontend
system, and you're debugging it
in your machine in front of you, you can
put a breakpoint in, you can stop it in
the middle, you can just kind of
poke in and see what's happening.
And you're going to figure out on a very
detailed level what the issues are.
But with a production system, you can't
really just stop it and go with that.
You want it to keep serving,
keep running, keep possibly working for
all the other people who are using it.
And so some of the tools that I'll
employ, I mean, first off, there's logs.
That's number one, hands down, the way
you're going to look at any problem.
Look back at the logs and
see did the usual thing
happen,or was an error thrown
somewhere along the way?
But sometimes the logs look fine.
And it doesn't help you any.
All it says is maybe it's really slow,
maybe this step took ten minutes and
you don't really know why.
It definitely takes putting on
your detective hat sometimes and
thinking really carefully about what
the code is doing under the hood.
It's not like you get
direct access all the time.
Sometimes you have to be
a little indirect about
poking at it from outside.